and we're jumping right into the action
here in an early game of evolved we've
got Goliath setting out just a little
bit ahead of our hunters I'm Aaron AC
chambers joined by co-founder of Turtle
Rock Studios Chris Ashton and before at
just as things get underway here Chris
talk to me about the early game strategy
for Goliath well he's going to try to
get away from the hunters as quickly as
possible and he's also going to try to
find food so first priorities run second
priorities fine food foods gonna give
you armor it's going to allow you to
stay up so right now he's just trying to
get distances and staging up so
important that one does it make you more
tanky but it gets a place for skill
points and all of those abilities he has
it is the snow's but right now he is
feeling a little bit weak we can see all
of the hunters have joined the
battlefield immediately we are going to
see the trapper drop it sounds like that
will help them track alive they're not
get even really gonna need it that much
as they've already got a bead on and we
can see his tracks on the ground there
and so as they continue to pursue him
out talk to me like obviously Goliath
gets a little bit of a start but what's
I mean you talk to me about the plans so
far give distance but how do you how do
you deal with knowing that you're going
to have all of these hunters barreling
down on you in just a moment well it's
kind of the path that he takes its being
careful where he runs it be if he scares
birds out of the out of fat that I'm
leaving leaving the signs behind so so
would you say subterfuge is a big part
near the game for the life
sure well we could see they've actually
caught up with him now and he is being
pursued into the jungle when he is using
the foilage of the best of his advantage
taking a little bit out of the way Pat's
and the son yeah it looks like Griffin's
peeled off from the rest of the pack and
that's it's a pretty common tactic for
the hunters to use where the rest of the
team flushes the monster out and Griffin
is able to trap him in that mobile arena
so it's a risky move but a lot of times
it pays off especially in the early
stages of the game it looks like though
Goliath knows what's going on and yeah
you can see if you see the red that he
can detect moving around him he knows
that's one of the hunters and he's
probably aware that that's going to be
the trapper and oh this creates such a
big opportunity for Goliath oh he's got
a bead on him and he doesn't know it all
he's in trouble and pounced on
immediately and this is one of those
risks you run and it's right at the core
of all the mechanics here and not in
evolve the fact that as one you're just
not powerful enough to deal with it as
for though at this stage especially you
can go to town now he's incapacitated
but not dead firing his pistol we're
gonna try to get him back up escrow fees
you can now as we seek alive begin to
fight I mean is this a fight he really
wants to take or is he just trying to do
some damage and eventually create some
space but see you know when he had
Griffin down who has an opportunity
there
get one guy down the fights going your
favor but they pick you back up so at
this point if I was Goliath I'd start
looking for an opportunity to get out of
their kind of see how well your offense
is going and if it's not going well you
tend to try to give up we can see he is
taking a lot of damage and now that all
four off we can see all of their
abilities beginning to synergize we can
see the shielding and the healing coming
up on the medics shielding coming from
the support we can see our trapper is
getting more and more involved he's
hitting very good hard feelings as our
food borderline immobilized the Goliath
and he has to deal with those before you
can do much of anything else and of
course our assault classes up front
close and personal once the tank for
damage and wants to deal as much damage
as we can but it does look like this
flight might be winding down you know if
they just got a bead on him yeah he's
gonna try to get away now he got tagged
by the medics tranquilizer dart he's
going to be able to still get away but
you can see those few steps he takes
between leaves he's so Sloan is born off
now but there's just so many skill shots
and oh look at the support God caught
out by one of those native plants on the
map and as we see the live try to find
some space and something else that he
talked to me about the design of the map
itself and and why it plays such a role
in such a competitive game we wanted it
to really be another player in the game
and in a sense the environment is a
third player
between the AI and the environment the
carnivorous plant these things create
opportunities for either team distinct
advantages well then we could see that
carnivorous plant has given the Goliath
quite an advantage and allowing him to
create some space they had to bust him
out it's slow daughters down and now
he's going to rank to he's leveling up
to the stage two in his evolution oh
he's got such a good high ground
position coming from downtown with a big
smash and that's gonna send them
scattering now it looks like he doesn't
want to fight just wanted to do what
damage he could to throw them off face
to get them confused but we see our
Traverse right behind him helping to
slow him down hitting those harpoons
let's see if he can catch up with him
yep he's got the mobile arena ready to
go gonna try to toss that out in front
of him then him with a harpoon there he
goes he's let it go and the leap not
enough harpooned him from behind and now
he's trapped now this is one of the
biggest gameplay mechanics as well that
mobile arena talk to you what about what
that means propose the Goliath player
and for the hunt for the glide that
means he's trapped in there for a
certain amount of time for the hunters
it's an opportunity for them to choose
his armor and just do some permanent
damage oh we can see all the trapper
actually got locked in the river now I
know there's a tyrant yes the tyrant
down in the river you have to be so
aware of your surroundings and evolve if
you're one of the hunters as he that's
actually a one-shot he's and he's not
just down and incapacitated there's no
resuscitating and that's going to be two
minutes he's off of the map entirely as
the live continues that just run over
the rest of his team what kind of I mean
put it in context for me how big of a
loss is it whenever you lose one of your
teammates like that has the hunters it's
huge they're designed to be co-op each
one of them has a very specific function
that is vital to their success so as
soon as one guys out there at a huge
disadvantage and we can see the lies
actually running here but since they're
down a man how does that change their
strategy how they going to approach
moduli well they definitely want to be a
lot more cautious if the life turns to
fight them he might be able to pull off
the win here so to be a little bit more
defensive they'll start anticipating
where you come and not gonna get they're
not going to chase them as closely as
they would normally they want to keep a
bead they don't want to lose him right
but they wanted they want to not really
force the fight themselves they want to
right field Griffey comes back don't
want to take that big of a risk now the
problem is we saw they had to stop and
deal with that tire another wise one of
them might get snatched the life is
actually utilizing one of the best
comeback mechanics we can see how banged
up he has a very nice visual system of
damage he's bruised he's bloody and you
can't reach inhale that involve if
you're the monster what you can do is
feed on wildlife and regen your armor
and that allows you to be just so taken
it looks like that's his number one
priority right now as the hunters just
wait on their trapper to get back on the
map but you know and now that they know
that he's coming back in we see already
the mines being late talk to me about
the strategy we're seeing employed by
the hunters right now so they're really
just trying to turtle up at the moment
they're trying to wait Griffin's got 30
seconds to come in
trying to do this last 30 seconds before
Griffin another big smash but he's able
to corner two of them now 20 seconds
right now it seems like such a short
amount of time but just look at how much
damage the Goliath is doing as they're
waiting for him to come back in and
lacking that immobilization means they
can't kind in effectively that's why
he's able to charge on top of them why
is able to bang them down so damn hard
and yet we're going to see already the
medic is down nice play from the support
though using first stealth ability
that's his class ability bought some
time for everyone to kind of reset but
they're still hurting the meantime
though the trappers just about the
parachute down the fights raging on that
talk to me how they're going to try to
change this up now with their back to
full strength they're just waiting for
Griffin to get back in assaults going to
try to draw his attention that lightning
rifle does a ton of damage so he'll try
to draw the agro and use his personal
shield to negate that a little bit and
oh we actually might see another
incapacitation on the support losing the
support is just crippling you know you
don't have your little strike that you
can call and you don't have the personal
shielding and this is going to happen
when you don't have that however with
the trapper back in that's going to give
them a chance to maybe kind of it so far
no good harpoons he's just continuing
the field massive amounts of damage and
run over this team who is once again
running at three-quarters strength we're
gonna see yep potentially another
incapacitation but he's setting up he's
landing another smash and yep there we
go once down that's going to be the
medic and the Goliath just continuing to
pound away setting up a huge assault on
No oh you jerks cutting the feed at the
very last minute that son it's not fair
man
you